une finale d'anthologie face à la russie
un exploit sans pareil pour une
génération
[Applaudissements]
un couronnement exceptionnelle pour les
ti bénéfices
[Applaudissements]
trois mois après kévin n'en revient
toujours pas
c'est une aventure de ben quoi c'était
dur difficile c'était top et voilà
c'était un rêve qui se réalise pour tout
le groupe et pour mon père et voilà
c'était c'est fou quoi
à sa demande le joueur de 31 ans n'a pas
enchaîné avec le roux pour souffler il
vient de débarquer sur les rives de la
loire une première en liga dans ce globe
trotter en huit ans kevin a
successivement foulée les plus beaux
parcs et italiens toulonnais turcs ou
chinois c'est plus simple parce que je
comprends la langue mais au niveau de
l'anus l'administratif c'est compliqué
alors france mais mais c'est très sympa
d'être d'être en france avec une petite
ella pouvoir par la force et de la femme
est anglaise donc c'est beau c'est cool
pour elle de pouvoir parler français
ambiance sud-américaine désormais au
club mais le cannois s'est parfaitement
intégré dans un groupe cosmopolite qui
allie jeunesse et expérience il apporte
sa polyvalence son savoir faire et
savoir vivre
c'est très important pour nommer
champion olympique mais beaucoup
d'espérance pour les petits creux voir
aussi je suis très content je pensais on
grand frère pour moi
une place qu ici exactement à ce jeune
papa
rôle fédérateur là dessus déjà
déjà il est trés polyglotte et du coup
il permet vraiment de faire un échange
entre eux tout le monde ça c'est
vraiment top et après là dessus il est
un petit peu plus mais un peu en rôle de
papa on va dire où ils essaient de gérer
tout en mettant toujours de la bonne
humeur donc c'est quand même très
agréable
[Applaudissements]
pour son retour en france kevin
cherchait un club prestigieux structuré
et ambitieux la régularité de tours plus
haut niveau l'a séduit aujourd'hui
malgré deux blessés majeurs et sans
pointu de métier le tvb caracole en tête
du championnat
on va gagner les matches
toujours un peu les matches très content
enfin assez compliqué difficile mais on
trouve les moyens de gagner et c'est ce
qui fait un bon groupe des mecs sympas
avec son drôle on vit bien on s'entraîne
dur et on se bat beaucoup sur le terrain
ont donc c'est vraiment top d'être avec
eux le tvb avait ciblé le futur champion
olympique signer dès le mois de mars il
l'a recruté pour 2 6 1 ça fait un boom
sur le public on le voit la sala est
quasiment plein à chaque match à un
baume au niveau des partenaires ce que
c'est quelqu'un qui est brillant dans la
communication qui est disponible qui est
agréable c'est le gendre parfait donc
voilà donc il est très important dans le
mécanisme de futurs du tours volley ball
une valeur sûre à l'image de sa fratrie
grand-père et pairs internationaux
mr néerlandais également volleyeuses et
deux frères basketteur pro une sacrée
famille canalis simplement le diplômé en
sociologie on regarde les matchs des uns
des autres et on est assez occupé ma
mère est très occupée elle se réveille
la nuit pour regarder les matches et
quand on a grandi ouais c'était une
esprit de compétition entre nous et je
pense que ça que nous a permis aussi de
s'améliorer et de grandir et de
performer à très haut niveau une
philosophie scène qui transpire sur le
terrain et pourrait bien contaminer le
reste de l'équipe avec bonheur